الاتفاق النهائي يوم واحد بابريل القادم
ان شاء الله
موعد جديد اعلنته القوه الموقعه على
الاتفاق لطارير لانهاء العمليه السياسيه
وتشكيل حكومه الفتره الانتقاليه وصفه
تاكيدات المكون العسكري بالمضي قدما
لتشكيل حكومه مدنيه
قل والله هذا المسار اذا ما استصحب القوه
الرئيسيه اذا ما استسحب كل السودانيين
سيتعسر قريبا ولن يستطيع ان يمضي لكن
الكتله الديمقراطيه واطرافا اخرى ما زالت
ترفض الانخراط في اجتماعات هذا المسار
وترى ان ورش هذه العمليه لم تخاطب جذور
الازمه الاسره الدوليه نحن نقول بشكل
مباشر انه المنطقه غد تدخل في مواجهه
سياسيه حقيقيه اذا وصل هذا الاتفاق
الايطالي مروره على قضيه شرق السودان دون
حلها بشكل شامل لن يرى الاتفاق الايطالي
نورا في اقليم شرق السودان وهذا في مسافه
الرساله واضحه لجميع الجهات المعنيه
بالاتفاق الايطالي
فيما تزال قوه تغيير الجذري التي تضم قوى
على راسها الحزب الشيوعي وبعض لجان
المقاومه تحمل لواء الرفض التام لاي حوار
مع المكون العسكري
[موسيقى]
الاتفاق الايطالي يعتبر ان القوه الجذريه
هي معارضه لهذا الاتفاق ستكون المعارضه
المدنيه السلميه في الشوارع وفي اي مكان
كمعارضه ولم يلتفت لهم وقدم لهم دعوات
كثيره ولكن لم يقبلوا بالجلوس مع
العسكريين الخمسه هنالك ايضا الاسلاميين
يضغط على الشارع والقوه السياسيه بان
يعودوا باي شكل من الاشكال عن طريق
الاذعان او فشل المرحله الانتقاليه تسمح
لهم بالعوده مره اخرى
فيما يظل الاسلاميون يرفضون ما اسموه
بالاقصاء ويبقى التحدي الاكبر بقدره هذه
الاطراف لتنفيذ ما اتفق عليه من مواقيت
لانهاء هذه العمليه السياسيه في ظل رفض
الفاعلين في المشهد السوداني قد يعقد
كثيرا من سير هذه العمليه سالم الهاشمي
العربي الخرطوم